[Musica]
entro ed esco dal carcere da una decina
d'anni e i miei reati non sono tentativi
di rapina ma sono reiterati tentativi di
fare del teatro dell'educazione della
terapia è qualcosa che assomiglia
all'arte la prima volta che sono entrata
in carcere era il 2008 me la ricordo
perfettamente perché per la prima volta
ho visto dei detenuti dei criminali dal
vero ed erano lì davanti a me e io che
mi chiedevo chissà se hanno spacciato
se hanno rubato non avranno mica
ammazzato qualcuno
perché mi sembrava veramente impossibile
erano delle persone assolutamente
normali davanti a me dei ragazzi degli
uomini alcuni erano anche decisamente
carini
da allora non ho più smesso e se mi
chiedete il perché è perché credo che in
nessun posto come in galera il mio agire
abbia portato della trasformazione
io vengo dal teatro dove tutte e
trasformazione e storie personaggi
materiali eppure in nessun posto come in
carcere ho potuto assaporare il potere
trasformativo del teatro e non sugli
oggetti o sulle storie ma direttamente
incisivamente nel nucleo delle persone
che per un po di tempo giocano a fare
gli attori e allora ho deciso di
scommetterci su questa trasformazione ed
è questa l'idea che secondo me ha senso
raccontarvi oggi di come abbia un
utilità è un senso portare della
trasformazione in carcere attraverso gli
strumenti del teatro e della
drammaterapia drammaterapia che di
drammatico ha soltanto il nome
perché in realtà è una terapia a
mediazione artistica che utilizza gli
strumenti appunto del teatro del dramma
per lavorare sulla prevenzione e sulla
cura sull'educazione e sulla
rieducazione
se voi ci pensate noi come società
civile diamo al carcere una missione che
è una missione trasformativa come se
fosse il cappello di un mago un cilindro
in cui mettiamo dentro un fazzoletto e
vola tiriamo fuori un coniglio
noi chiediamo al carcere di contenere
delle persone fare una qualche magia e
restituirci delle persone trasformate in
persone oneste e perbene
abbiamo messo dentro ovviamente dei
delinquenti questa magia non funziona
sempre purtroppo non funziona neanche
molto spesso visto i dati altissimi
delle recidive
però è una missione trasformativa noi
quella che noi diamo un istituto
penitenziario
e allora la mi sono chiesta quali sono
gli strumenti del dramma e del teatro
che possono essere utili e in qualche
modo concorrere a portare questo
cambiamento questa trasformazione che
noi legittimamente come società civile
ci aspettiamo che lì dentro avvenga
quindi un passaggio da un delinquente è
una persona per bene secondo me ci sono
molti degli strumenti del teatro della
pratica teatrale che possono essere
utili per operarlo questo cambiamento
ve ne racconto alcuni che però secondo
me sono i più significativi
innanzitutto a far teatro si fa fatica
si fa una grandissima fatica io immagino
che pochi di voi sappiano tutto il
lavoro che c'è dietro due ore di
spettacolo lavoro anche fisico proprio
in termini di sudore da parte degli
attori che sono sul palcoscenico
ecco molti degli attori detenuti con cui
lavoro io con cui lavoriamo noi in
carcere sono delle persone che nella
loro vita non hanno fatto fatica
un giorno solo perché in carcere
eccessiva per disperazione anche per
mancanza di mezzi culturali e materiali
ma ci si va anche per amore di una vita
comoda conosco delle persone che non si
sono mai alzate alle 6 del mattino per
andare a lavorare alle 7
perché i soldi a fine mese entrano per
delle dei canali che sono più facili e
più comodi quando si fa teatro tutto
questo non funziona se devi fare uno
spettacolo o vieni alle prove o fai le
prove o studi la memoria o provi 120
mila volte quello singolo gesto quella
battuta quella quella partitura di
movimenti o semplicemente uno spettacolo
non si crea se se non vieni alle prove
non puoi pensare di mandare uno
scugnizzo che faccia lui le prove e
tutti presenti alla fine la sera del
debutto a prendere gli applausi perché
non funziona così
ed ecco esattamente questo quello che
noi stiamo insegnando a questi detenuti
nel fare teatro
che tanto lavori tanto ottiene stiamo
insegnando la fatica per ottenere un
risultato che non è scontato ma è un
risultato che deve essere sudato e
guadagnato e stiamo insegnando una
disciplina e io credo che all'interno
del cappello del mago si sa bene che una
disciplina in qualche momento la si
apprenda la si possa imparare un altro
degli strumenti che da il teatro è
quello del poter lavorare sulla
collaborazione che è diverso dall
associazione a delinquere sia
l'associazione a delinquere che il
lavoro di gruppo in altri ambiti hanno
alcuni principi condivisi ma diverse
sono sicuramente i metodi e gli scopi
perché il teatro per antonomasia e non a
scopo di lucro non riesce ad essere a
scopo di lucro né anche per chi lo fa di
mestiere e quindi figuriamoci per tutti
gli altri insomma il teatro se non ci
sei se non fai quello che devi fare
rischi di compromettere lo spettacolo di
tutti in carcere potrebbero fartela
pagare ma nel fartela pagare non ci
guadagna nessuno se c'è il tuo compagno
dietro le quinte che non si ricorda la
battuta che non sa quando deve entrare
ecco quello è un problema tuo perché non
ne va del suo spettacolo ne va del tuo
spettacolo del vostro spettacolo c'è
soltanto il nostro in quel momento lui
il suo errore
la sua distrazione sono una cosa che
deve riguardare te ea cui tu devi porre
rimedio perché non puoi scappare salvare
la tua pelle in quel momento non c'è la
tua pelle c'è soltanto la nostra pelle e
questo credo che sia il germe del del
senso civico di una responsabilità
civile che manca o che è mancata a chi
delinque e noi stiamo provando a fare
questo ad insegnare a queste persone
attraverso il teatro a prendersi cura
degli altri delle cose degli altri come
se fossero mie perchè sono mie
in quel momento sono nostre perché siamo
una compagnia teatrale e nel grande
siamo una polis
siamo una società
e poi c'è un altro tema che a me sta
particolarmente a cuore il teatro
permette di riabilitare la propria
immagine di sé si fa tantissimo parlare
in ambito pedagogico ed educativo di
quanto sia importante fornire ai bambini
nella fase della crescita delle immagini
positive di se stesse quindi migliorare
l'autostima voi immaginate che il teatro
e il carcere anche il teatro è piena di
bambini che hanno dei corpi muscolosi
palestrati e tatuati brutti e cattivi a
volte ma che dentro conservano in uno
spirito infantile che tante volte è
stato traumatizzato perché in carcere ci
si va per amore della suddetta vita
comoda ma in carcere c'è anche chi ci
finisce perché non ha nessuna
possibilità di un altro destino c'è chi
li dentro non ha vissuto altro se non
violenza se non delinquenza
c'è chi ha sempre vissuto ai margini
della legalità del lecito
chi nella sua vita imparato soltanto a
cavarsela da solo a dare a prendere
delle botte e soprattutto c'è chi non si
è mai sentito dire bravo complimenti ma
che cosa bella che hai fatto sei stato
bravo questa e la mia domanda
fondamentale come pensiamo di
trasformare di chiedere un cambiamento
delle persone che di se stesse sanno
soltanto di essere dei buoni a nulla né
poco di buono dei delinquenti dei
cattivi come facciamo a chiedere una
persona di mantenersi nel giusto se
questa persona di se stessa sa soltanto
di essere un delinquente perché nessuno
gli ha mai detto quando era grande e
così che c'era una possibilità diversa
come possiamo chiedere a qualcuno di
mantenersi nel giusto se lui questo
giusto semplicemente non lo conosce il
teatro permette a molti di questi
detenuti di percepirsi per la prima
volta in un'altra maniera di prendere un
applauso di prendere un complimento voi
provate ad immaginarvi di mettervi
davanti allo specchio e non poter
elencare una cosa buona di valore che
avete fatto nella vostra vita che
motivazione avreste di mantenervi nella
giustizia un po di mesi fa lo abbiamo
portato in carcere a busto arsizio una
compagnia di dieci detenuti
c'erano più di 500 persone a vederci
forse volevano vedere che faccia avevano
questi brutti ceffi hanno scoperto che
sono delle persone normali alcuni anche
dei buoni attori e quando si è aperto il
sipario si è sentita levare dalla platea
la voce di una bambina che chiamava papà
questa bambina aveva visto suo papà
willy sul palcoscenico che è che usciva
per recitare e questa bimba suo papà
willy lo vede da tre anni soltanto
un'ora la settimana nella sala dei
colloqui che è una sala abbellita ma è
comunque la sala di una galera ci sono
altre persone e il suo papà lo sente per
10 15 minuti la settimana per telefono
voi pensate quanto bene ha fatto a
questa bambina vedere quella sera il suo
papà willy libello sul palcoscenico
brava plaudito da tutti che sapeva
recitare che faceva ridere per quella
bambina su papa a quella sera era è
tornato ad essere il supereroe che ogni
papa dovrebbe essere per una figlia e
provate a pensare quanto bene ha fatto a
questo papa potersi far vedere così
dalla propria famiglia una famiglia che
ha deluso
una famiglia che allontana e di cui non
può prendersi cura una famiglia verso la
quale sicuramente si sente in colpa
questo significa cambiare la propria
immagine di sé
questo significa permettere di
percepirsi in un modo diverso in un modo
che è buono costruttivo socialmente
accettabile ed accettato e questo per un
detenuto che presto diventerà presto o
tardi diventerà un ex detenuto e
importante poterlo fare
devono potersi immaginare con una
potenzialità di buono interno per
poterla deridere a quel cambiamento e lo
stesso modo è importante che la società
possa immaginare una potenzialità
positiva in quelle persone perché
altrimenti come facciamo a ri ri
inglobarle come possiamo poi
reimpiegarli costruttivamente
questo è quello che stiamo tentando di
fare all'interno del carcere di busto da
una decina d'anni con questa nostra
avventura teatrale e abbiamo fatto un
associazione di recente per poi riuscire
a farlo un po meglio
si chiama all'oblò perché noi abbiamo
un'idea di carcere che è come una sorta
grande nave che porta delle persone da
una libertà a un'altra libertà una
prossima libertà e noi vogliamo esserci
in questo percorso perché questo
tragitto sia il più significativo
possibile e per poter fare in modo che
l'arrivo alla prossima libertà sia un po
migliore di quello precedente quello che
stiamo facendo attraverso gli strumenti
del teatro e della drammaterapia e
rieducazione rieducare che significa
riportare ad un ambito di di dignità
delle persone che la dignità l'hanno
persa che stanno giustamente pagando per
quello che hanno fatto ma finché questa
dignità non viene in qualche maniera
ripristinata a mio avviso non è
possibile in nessun modo un reale
cambiamento nelle parole del mio grande
amico pino detenuto di lunga data che ha
acquistato un impatto di saggezza
rieducare e ridare dignità nelle mie
parole rieducare è restituire al bello
perché io sono anche quello che gli
altri vedono di me e se per una sera una
platea intera invece di vedere il
disgraziato il delinquente di me vede un
attore bravo capace che sa far ridere e
sa far piangere che sa far emozionare
può essere che anch'io scelga di aderire
a quello che per una sera gli altri
hanno visto a quell'immagine buona di me
che gli altri hanno visto e può essere
che io scelga di cambiare ritornare a
crederci può essere
[Applauso]